[Music]
welcome to Street cocoa everybody what's
going on we're coming at you a day early
oh look at this we're gonna play some
next muck you know which is insane
coming out today early on Tuesday today
because we have a bunch of meetings on
Wednesday so now we're gonna be doing on
Tuesday surprise and you're welcome
today we're playing this game called
next machina he looks as you can tell
from the below stuff that's happening
completely insane it's very exciting so
I wore a completely insane shirt today
there you go it's the kind of shirt
where I if you can't decide whether
we're plaid or camo get you shirts that
can do both you know I don't think this
game is that long so I think we're gonna
do is we're gonna try to beat the entire
game on the stream let's do it hello
Sayid what's up metallics Evan what's up
jungle gym mania Oh metallics seven oh
you got to be a dick already
well dick count number one there we go I
hope everybody had a fantastic weekend
what am i doing I'm gonna do some
experienced here now this is the kind of
game I love because basically all you
need are these two sticks kind of oh
Jesus
all you need are it's the kind of it's a
kind of game where one stick runs and
the other stick shoots it's that easy
you know and you just it's just absolute
chaos which is super fun have you guys
ever played that game zombie apocalypse
that that indie game which by the way
was equally awesome not equally awesome
to this but very close it was a similar
kind of mechanics did somebody say this
is an Ikea shirt dope IKEA fashion I
think IKEA would be the opposite right
IKEA would be more like understated and
simple I think and by the way I just
want it known that it is really hard yes
seizure warning agreed really hard to
play this and look at the chat so be
nice to me
all right and Beth isn't here so I'm all
by my lonesome surrounded alone no Beth
Beth's in the office I mean she's here
today but she's just not
you're beautiful Pete thank you for the
kind words doesn't just get hurt what
happened to my awesome gun hey guys this
week gun it just got destroyed um also
Oh - explosion gotta love that why are
there just people wandering around in
this insane war zone
Oh not fair that's not cool
oh look it's like centipede oh Jesus
let's get out of the way though showing
and playing this game on this Hans I'm
hoping Connor will be here twin-stick
shooter baby anybody else got some good
twin-stick shooter action they like I
invited Conan I always invite Conan but
you know he pretends he has work to do
Yeah right whatevs ah we just went to
Israel which was oh it got killed notice
me senpai all right Edward gf I'm great
and I've noticed you like I said it's
gonna be hard for me to notice people in
the chat so if it's gonna be a game of
notice me senpai we're gonna it's gonna
be a long stream for everybody I got a
secret human save mother f r1 LT oh he's
coming
what's up Tina's flowers did you name
yourself Tina's flowers because you own
a flower shop just because you like
flowers
either way is completely cool just gonna
stand here put on some pants
I got pants yo they're black pants
that's why it looks like I'm wearing no
pants because they match my black legs
I don't know I'm talking about yeah
arcade games are simple and complicated
oh I got killed and they're made to just
eat up quarters man you know like I and
it's funny now that you're an adult oh
the human got killed well he shouldn't
have been wandering around in a war zone
I have to say now that I'm an adult I
can choose to spend like $100 on an
arcade game so what I did was there was
this game I used to love you guys
remember the t2 shooter game with like
the Uzis anybody remember that the
shield I'll take that what I went to
this place downtown it's called bar 82
and it's one of those new one of those
new like bars that's also an arcade
that's really fun and oh that's a lot of
guys and I was just like I'm gonna spend
as much money as it takes to beat this
game so I just got like a hundred
dollars in quarters and I just started
playing and it's ridiculous
how much it kind of cheats like it's
amazing how much it cheats to just suck
quarters out of your pocket it's not
fair
it was disgusting so shame on you t2
people uh-oh because yet do love flowers
and did not a name yourself fair enough
I mean that's as good a reason as any
all right that is a lot of dudes I said
this before but this feels like what the
game starship are what the movie
Starship Troopers kind of should have
been you know just chaos hey you choose
amazing yeah it's super fun and it's
sometimes it's fun hold I'll put go put
people on the big screen which is dope
oh that's bad what just happened how do
you remember to use my - dude they're
big screens they'll kind of or maybe
just it's just above the bar that
they'll put people up
there's also dudes who hang out there
who are really good at Street Fighter -
like champions so if you ever want to go
against the street fighter - champion
now you know where to go get away from
my friend
[Music]
I love it ah there's a I think there's a
death limit of Heil Malik can you move
the right chat over a little bit so I
can see it to the left there's a death
limit there's I have 99 continues I
think which seems like a lot and then
you see how insane this game is and it
feels like not enough I'm gonna put that
out there sometimes guys not moving is
the only move you know not a fan of the
pink lasers oh that's that's I can't see
anything now man okay dude thanks you
can just move over the window it's okay
um yeah this this game looks like it
would give you anxiety but actuality it
kind of makes me less anxious that's
like I don't have time to be anxious you
know it's got a go for it
[Music]
lot of lasers over here
[Music]
I didn't see it this weekend Perry
Thicke what do we think about it are we
happy are we sad is there I heard that
the kids are really good but the actual
stuff with it was not actually that
great it kind of feels like a little
hokey not hokey but like it's not creepy
like it should be it's more just like
big big jump scares I don't know all
dumbass humans who have been wandering
around in a war zone safe you're welcome
ooh a boss ooh I like this this looks
like it's just shooting a giant stream
of cotton candy at me I got this dumb
sword a lot of it come over here and get
this thing yeah oh yeah baby
oh this laser is dope oh come on aah
cotton candy Gabi
[Music]
sure shooting a lot of deaths heads at
me this is kind of just making me want
candy Smash TV was done by Eugene
Gervais is that who did this
I hope there'll be another NBA star on
the show soon bashing music pants there
you go
residentsleeper there were jump scares
are now yeah Mary Mary otter I will say
this game has awesome music very EDM
playlist how idiom this looks like it
could be at an EDM show this is
something that would come up on the
stage now I love Tim Curry and the
original it was so great and part of the
thing I do think like horror and comedy
both kind of can benefit sometimes from
low budgets you know like have you ever
seen that Kolchak The Night Stalker or
even the original in a TV series just
the fact that it was so just the fact
that it it was so low budget kind of
made it more creepy in a certain way in
my opinion how do I get over there there
we go
gotta save my dumbass friends you know
[Music]
whoa flying now man and I have no
weapons
this sucks not Camille save this dude
[Music]
there we go you like I'm going the exact
same way I did before they got me killed
yep I don't learn there we go got him
I'll take that weapon spread thank you
I will say like I think contra invented
a number of weapons that vary oh whoops
very few video game makers have actually
been able to improve upon
very few video game makers came to
better than the original contra although
I think Doom got really close Doom halo
you have to kneedler's in there get away
from my pal
[Music]
that shield flashy CGI can ruin the
emerging yeah I agree and a lot of
people have kind of said to me that they
think that oh [ __ ] that they've also
said oh [ __ ] to me but uh that it felt
kind of like a via a cartoon or a video
game at points which isn't necessarily
bad obviously we love video games but I
think if you're talking about a movie
where you want to feel immersed and
scared that's a hard thing
I don't play MMOs now I mean you can't
really smoke half a crack rock you know
I can't get involved in in giant things
but I do want to check out destiny - has
anyone played and what do you guys think
and should I blow these things up I
don't know is this a good thing - a
secret human oh why don't I just use my
- you idiot what's wrong with you Oh
Starship Troopers
tim's acting equals bet better than jump
scares any day i completely agree
he's just so creepy human lost
Oh what some of the pink balls man Dumon
halo are kind of yeah I guess they're
kind of like the same are they like the
same game I don't know I wouldn't say so
I wouldn't say do mihaela or like the
same game I mean aren't I mean if we're
going that way
oh [ __ ] you aren't all games cynllun how
do you play this game Lola
well one stick moves you the other stick
shoots so that's kind of the keys to
keep moving and not look at the chat
while you're a how about to get murdered
these pink balls are killing me man if I
just go wow this thing's really on my
ass huh deci two's lit huh Wow I'm just
getting killed right and left Blair pay
attention alright I have to pay
attention I only have 98 more continues
you guys I can't let them go to waste
[Music]
[Music]
oh I see it's the pinball things that
were screwing me up
[Music]
Rishi thank you so much the weight loss
thing
I'm glad yeah it meant a lot to me to
write it so I'm glad it meant a lot to
other people as well yeah it's a weird
thing to have people know that much
about my personal life but that's a good
thing I think it helped people and yeah
man get after it you can do it
just like you only I wear Dumber shirts
I make poor clothing choices get these
things also who's building all these
things
your son has anxiety give them a spliff
well this is the Internet so I can't
actually give you anything nor would I
give up a slip by the way I mean you
could buy it off me I guess if I had a
spliff I don't give out free spliffs
unless someone is truly ouch deserving
how about we play something from the
PlayStation one era ah okay like what
what would be something we should play
from Playstation one earth there's a
shield up there I saw I gots to get it
[Music]
like the shield's gonna come in real
handy in about two seconds
whoa can't save everybody there we go
nailed it
I think about RPG games I love RPG game
well I don't like turn-based combat I
like these
I think in recent years there's been a
really cool movement to oh god that was
man close-quarters dude there's been a
great movement to RPG like fallouts a
great example RPGs that have you know
real-time combat which I I really like
the turn-based combat I just I can't get
into it man it's just like hey here
comes some action and then like wait
five turns to do anything
[Music]
I'm feeling a little bit like the bride
and killbill here man
and so get a little rough
[Music]
Oh baby
[Music]
oh this thing is on my ass come on man
oh Jesus
Crash Bandicoot is great I've never
actually played Crash Bandicoot right
here very good things about it it's kind
of pure let's mix it up up here you know
let's move let's a little spice work
like they say in improv you know a
little space work whoa using my dash
here to great effect
[Music]
thanks Tina see you later
[Music]
oh wow I just lost a lot of humans look
man you gotta make choices you know
sometimes it's survival of the fittest
Mass Effect is great was that a
Playstation one I don't think so I just
feel like first of all I heard Mass
Effect Andromeda is not good
unfortunately for my man dunkey you guys
ever watched video game donkey that
duties so favorite video game reviewer
[Music]
but I heard Massa fighting with drivers
not good not good but the first two
first three mass effects they're
supposed to be great and dramatists for
right ah dota2 I'm terrible at games
like dota I'll try it I'll try anything
man oh now I got a laser now you're all
in big trouble
let me just carve through these guys the
lasers great
we have a channel on twitch what are you
talking about
your what you're watching our twitch
channel oh no I guess you're on YouTube
we have we also have a twitch channel
then I'm also looking at the insane
trilogy Oh then out see this guy I don't
I don't need I don't need this dude
firing a million things a minute that
doesn't seem fair get away from my
friends one human died oh this guy looks
like a real jerk but I gots a laser fear
my laser [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
loving this music this game is amazing
music somebody told me that this this is
on Spotify which is incredible oh wow
whatever that thing is sucks
[Music]
extra life I'll take it yeah oh the
laser is my favorite thing oh great now
we got these this thing is a real pain
in the ass man I got lasers too bro
yeah Oh God this laser is the greatest
weapon ever it's basically just like an
electric boner oh this sucks I'm not
even hitting him Emma I could barely see
the dude I'm just going off a feel here
yeah flying now man
this is dude die
er he's not coming over my side of the
screen there it is
[Music]
bro edicts there we go
come on man you can't be this strong
there we go got him it was playing that
I'd run out of downloadable content with
the O but it was terrible so this
crashing and ER chrome this game is
killer
Michelle is a Zara I'm feeling great
wickedness nostalgia quality to this
game 90s feel I agree Chris if you guys
are just joining us for playing next
machina today this game is amazing I
think it just came out I think it's a
indie game super fun thanks ex excellent
H excellent the brahmic a joke oh you
found us and now I think things are just
gonna get harder I have a feeling he
says as he dies melee I need that laser
back though this seems my saving grace
whoa baby
damn it
oh the - I need a better - no guys only
have 96 continues I need all these
things
damn it
[Music]
ah well I got a secret human near autumn
otama what sneer at aha Tama
[Music]
not sure when you're a ton of it oh man
I'm losing these humans ah yeah the
humans I know what smart-bomb give me
something else sword ah sword blows neck
- have you guys seen duckies review of
knack - it's amazing
[Music]
whoa baby flying now man I don't know
how I'm surviving this but apparently
it's happening oh there's a human up
there that doesn't seem fair 100
continues seems like too much and then
you look at this and it doesn't feel
like too much at all I just started this
scheme like five minutes ago and already
I can't even keep track of what's
happening
[Music]
I'm wearing pants bro I mean I'm not
wearing pants just clear out the area
bit now great I have a sword cool oh
[Music]
definitely me that shield it's gonna be
hard to get in here and see this dude Oh
what was that laser from behind on cool
bro Conan would suck at this game I
invited him we'll see if he shows up my
guess is probably not
he's scared of me and this game ah and
I'm scared of that guy what's the game
of the character shoots the finger gun
I'm not sure you're talking about
exactly
cool died check it out Zayn Ali what
should I check out I missed it sorry I'm
playing I'm killing 9000 bad guys while
I'm talking to you
vote for no pants guys you don't want to
see me of no pants
there's rashes and things down there
it's no fun for anybody let's run it
this way damn it oh this is a tough one
okay I need to I need to buckle down
here guys
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
weapon range I need that this guy will
give me something I'm gonna just stand
here and just destroy everything you
know sometimes the only way to win is
not to play oh you're a jerk there's a
lot of dudes on the screen right now ah
before I could get there I want some of
my favorite things about streaming with
you guys or how 96 continues how
obsessed with God what is that is how
obsessed to check ah how obsessed the
chat gets with like ridiculous things
sometimes
today it's No Pants I appreciate you
chat I appreciate you you know I don't
appreciate this level and being hemmed
in like this is this continued 95 guys
see you thought everybody was like 99
continues is too many but the makers of
next machina are like nope this is gonna
be super hard that's just enough
multiplier up I certainly need it
goddamn it
my man I'm doing good and by the way I
say my man all the time so I appreciate
your this is tough I'm gonna need to not
look at the chat for one second hold on
hold please
when I have that shitty gun it's so
[ __ ] hard to kill these guys you
really need all the guns hashtag all the
guns these things can eat a giant turd
sandwich I think it's a waste of bullets
sorry Bing bong I can only do nine
things at once so when I'm doing 10
things something has to stop make George
Clancy plate Jordan doesn't like video
games Jordan doesn't like a lot of
things but he also doesn't like video
games 90-foot see now we're get where
we're going through these quick dude
[Music]
[Music]
save this dude boom
what happened those games we've done
start level 1 what we played this game
the last time we streamed which was hell
blades since she was sacrifice and that
game if you die and it's a long-ass game
you die for realsies
forever and it was heroin and my herring
I'm a horrifying dammit Conan is still
Drake you froze Oh lead Jordan is still
drinking rose elitist espresso machine
of course why would you think he
wouldn't be
[Music]
that's how he does man these guys are
fast so I get it blowing these guys up
gives me this there we go yeah I'd love
to do a street for the NES classic when
it comes out oh now I got the laser now
y'all are in big trouble
[Music]
and lasers dope yeah I don't really care
about the humans right now dude I got
other problems like everything else
chasing me
saved him I love how this dude flies
around too by the way
oh god this is terrible what the hell
we're doing a running thing now we got a
run oh this is sucks this sucks kids oh
this is terrible blow up let's go oh
[Music]
come on I guess start over [ __ ] you
this is the worst this is really hard
ah this is ridiculous this is we're not
this is where 99 this 493 of my
continues are gonna go guys
I'm just warning you right now ice I
suck at levels like this yeah did you I
don't know if you guys have seen the new
Jordan scrap rear ambles not about Star
Wars but people ask is Jordan really
like that and the answer is look at that
scrap yes he's like that he's just like
that that's just him I went backwards I
gotta kill this thing
I can't go around this Boulder huh
I might not be able to save all these
humans I'm starting to have a feeling I
[Music]
just looked in the chat for a second
it's not Indiana Groundhog Day this is
like a new awesome contract it is it's a
really hard except they give you the lot
oh they give you the lives up top all
right we're gonna make it through this
guys here we go all right buckle down
I hate dungeon run I hate Temple Run I
hate any running games I hate and I also
hate running in real life
I like stupid shirts I like crunchy
Cheetos
[Music]
oh god damn it this is tough man
what's the death count on do we know the
death count today that you know what we
should have started adding up the death
count
[Music]
Blair pull it together
where's my sub button what do you mean
my sub button oh you mean like in the
thing I don't know where the sub button
is I can't look for it right now and
running for my life this is like the
most screwed up Indiana Jones oh come on
all right here we go guys
19th sounds about right
what do you guys think about a death
death count of 19 Oh
weapon spread is gonna save my life
right now here we go
[Music]
let's go get me out of here yes we did
it kids oh but then we died immediately
but you know what we're away from the
boulder and that's what matters take the
weapons spread oh my god that's so many
guys tasty solemn or down to ninety I
want to beat this game in this stream I
think we can do it kids
[Music]
finally I'm a shield I got destroyed
immediately now so that's 20 deaths I
think right give me that guy no [ __ ]
[Music]
miss me Oh just work my way through
these guys quickly
[Music]
damnit I'm not familiar with the PAL
version of contra
[Music]
probotector that doesn't seem like a
real thing probotector
[Music]
oh the - explosions great ah the laser
my pal the laser we're back yeah I got a
laser - what do you think about that
move laser baby
I would love to the clues came from our
a lot to see if we can pull it off a lot
of clueless gamers a lot of clues gamers
are all about timing so we'll see but
you know what we're shooting another
clues gamer next week I believe no two
weeks f bat
[Music]
I don't care about that I just love my
laser who should say pleaser
[Music]
ha gotcha oh Jesus we got a bad guy
hey bad guy do you like lasers
oh you're shooting pink balls how
original oh wow eating a lot of pink
balls wow there's a lot of can't quite
get a hold of guys pattern
oh wow we're back oh and we got the
laser still feeling good looking good at
least we're feeling good he'll Tron what
an original name l-tron oh jesus did not
see that coming
so now we got to start all over cool
cool this is great
very excited give me just give me that
laser that's all I care about
[Music]
oh that was this is all terrible missed
me really could use the shield there bro
[Music]
the new wise game what's the new wise
game is it just called wise is it about
letters that are sometimes vowels and
sometimes not vowels this game rise with
wreck-it Ralph I've never seen wreck-it
Ralph does that make me a bad person
what's fury I've never played the period
favorite move
I get the shield in that immediately
lose this yield
cool ah thank you
Beth is currently in the office she's
doing a lot of stuff for our upcoming
Israel shows September 19th very
exciting hope you guys all like it
rocket launcher I'll take it
I don't want the sword detonators fun
[Music]
now this thing sucks
oh well combatant do be great we did do
a gamer the [ __ ]
I haven't played packed about what's
path of Exile we did do a gamer that was
like Atari games I think kind of ripped
through those which is pretty fun I
gotta say you know those games have
their own rhythm and I mean they're all
very hard is the thing in a certain way
video games have kind of I know I'm
saying as I'm saying this I know how
ridiculous us out but teams have gotten
a little bit easier as just because of
the elec unlimited continues and stuff
so yeah I mean Atari games are simple
and very difficult [ __ ] as is this game
ah
j-dog I mean I like doing celebrity I
like doing gamers with just me and Conan
just because it's easier to control
there's always there's always a you know
there's just when you put a celebrity in
them in the mix it's just another thing
that you have to worry about laser
perfect but I also really like the
celebrity ones I mean some of the
celebrity ones have been super funny
which is great so in Conan I think
prefers doing once with the celebrities
these days
which obviously I can't fault him for
because he's the boss
[Music]
what's a smart one now just a smart bomb
around me that's dumb cool so I have
zero weapons going up against this guy
great against hell Tron I feel you
what's funny is like I don't gonna have
a weapon range I'm gonna get destroyed
what's really funny to me is like this
is terrible there's no way I'm gonna
beat this guy what's really funny to me
is guys or villains with with like evil
sounding names or names that try to
sound evil perfect because I always I
always think about their moms like
making fun of them you know like telling
them to do so oh wow this bad telling
them to do something like hell Tron go
take out the trash hell Tron can you
please clean your room these things next
clueless gamer coming soon hopefully
we're shooting it I think in a next week
of the week after
let's get a gaming cat for the office
dude what gaming cats are the worst for
gaming all cats want to do is just sit
on your keyboard I can't think of a
worse pet to have for gaming now a
gaming fish
now you're talking so fish just sits
there and does nothing cool continue
what about what's our what's our
deathcount O'Malley do you think it's
about 30 oh sure just add on some laser
now see if I can get if I can just get
to the bad guy with this laser man I got
it I'm all set
ah oh come on give me that laser bro oh
that guy's it
[Music]
I'm saving my laser for when he stands
there like a doof
[Music]
ah Timmy oh don't make me continue gotta
keep that laser no I'm not playing smart
at all
there we go
make that hell Tron if that is your real
name it's probably Perry or something I
feel like if you if you've named
yourself hell Tron I'm not saying that
his pit and that's 84 hell trans real
name is probably Aaron my what about if
my real name is hell Tron in your face
so it sucks you want to give me a
different one detonators fine laser yes
oh I'll handle the laser baby
all hail the laser
[Music]
or is he
[Music]
no comes skating in my area why is this
galleys this guy's like a hell trying to
figure skating champion its kind of
skate around doesn't he Ultron does
exactly what I do when I have when I'm
wearing socks on a hardwood floor so
it's hard to be like truly scared of
them
[Music]
Oh
Oh God then he's kind of skating towards
me it's a little hairy oh Jesus Christ
[Music]
okay
PFT talk with PFT talk whose came with
the president hard pass
be more weapons dude plants your weapons
right now
goddamnit there's no way I'm beating
this guy with zero weapon some I'll just
give up
[Music]
come on hell Tron I'll pull out Tompkins
I love Paul Tompkins who's on the show
tonight that's my question we have a
little Chris Hardwick
we have band Parcells who I just saw in
soundcheck and they are sounding Joe
and I just died death count sounds 54
sounds about right
that's 55 this is about this has got to
be our biggest death stream I think man
I'm just getting real sword all this
sword sucks why even make it a weapon
cool mysteries this is a great game
you're just joining us for playing next
machina I'll take the detonator all day
cool great I'm just kidding
no sword no ladies are yes a power shot
the poor man's laser
[Music]
all right can I change the difficulty Oh
[Music]
sword sucks
I'm just getting destroyed Jungle Jim I
appreciate your comment it's way too
long for me to read while playing this
game but I appreciate it Jordan I did
get married 100% Jordans a happily
married man well I don't know happily
but he's definitely married
hey open gamer thanks for the
introduction
oh sweet it gave me a multiplier just
doing what exactly
laser yes oh yeah love me that laser
I don't I think it's a little bit
cheating for this dude to appear before
the other guys have died but that's just
me Oh God
I hate this guy this guy is this guy
sucks this guy is the worst
he'll Chalmers he'll charm is the best
man in Jordan's wedding yes that's true
laser
[Music]
boom alright let's go let's go [ __ ] you
hell tron okay fair enough
note to self don't make fun of hell
truant off the laser you can only shoot
once I'm learning a lot about the laser
kids perfect dead
the key to hell Tron I think is to not
move around when you start shooting that
stuff
[Music]
oh my god dude really likes his balls
oh you know what when I move around
he'll Tron moves around that's
interesting
I'm just discovering new things about
Hell Tron Jesus Christ now get that
laser [ __ ] No No maybe continue
[Music]
it's gonna do this forever hell Tron or
what
[Music]
yes l-tron has been destroyed no death
death count from the shadows is right 78
we think we're doing I still think we
can beat this game in six minutes I will
play Battlefront 2 and it comes out for
sure
oh man you know what
that's a disheartening death right off
the bat just work through the pain kids
work through the pain
[Music]
cool dead uh sometimes Conan joins me
but it's been a while it's got things on
his mind
things to do is they say cool a lot of
dead guys here
it's like to--you project and Helldivers
it's oh yeah I played a little hell
diverse is pretty fun
[Music]
[Music]
boom his balls are getting bigger that's
true uh do we not have a subscribe
button [ __ ] me
I thought we did but now people are
saying we don't so I'm very confused
[Music]
I hate the ring things that's my new
thing I hate cool the ring I don't
Coenen does like his celebrities alright
[Music]
oh it's a lot of lasers got it
perfect
yeah what's up Gingras yes next machine
which you obviously saw me play last
night on my own stream which is why
we're playing this today but I loved it
so much last night
[Music]
perfect I've never hated the color pink
more than today and I normally like the
color pink I have a lot of pink shirts a
big fan of pink not a fan of
[Music]
man ring sting
Tate the ring hate the ring hate the
ring
hate the ring simple geometry this feels
like geometry wars a little bit I'm it
was created own YouTube channel like
PewDiePie yeah you know I do have my own
twitch channel which you're more than
welcome to give me that shield to follow
along I just try to stream as much as
possible which these days is about once
a week twice a week tops the ring thing
can blow me so hard that guy can eat it
I'll take that extra life if I get an
extra life does that make me take one
off the death counter no I don't think
so there we go
get me out of here ah it's hard to
stream you have a family and a job I
don't know a family or a job I don't get
paid for working at Conan they just let
me hang around like that guy in the
office space by the way the robots
should definitely also get killed by the
lasers that doesn't seem fair that guy
is overcompensating for something for
sure
[Music]
yeah
yeah my hand oh don't think my hands
aren't extremely sweaty because they are
so sweaty look at all these God God I
just feel like the most popular gallon
school everybody wants to shoot me with
their pink laser their pink things there
you go thank you oh not fair hate the
ring thing ring things are the worst
I'll take that extra life thank you a
lot of lasers up here kids lotta lasers
got to watch yourself you want to wear
eye protection you want to make sure
you're wearing loose-fitting clothes
case you know your laser hits you and
starts lighting your hands on fire yes I
am the guy on the couch from the movie
half-baked that's exactly me what was
that guy's name not Jim Jarmusch Jim
Breuer that's right I saw him and
Chappelle before Chappelle is really big
in Ann Arbor do stand-up and is really
funny
they were both hilarious what happened
what happened to Jim Breuer anybody know
he was on SNL I remember that
oh that's right that's right oh my god I
should sell Team Coco hand
antiperspirant do they have hand
antiperspirant is that a thing that they
make or do you just rub antiperspirant
on your hands as I would imagine it's
probably just regular antiperspirant
right
[Music]
[Music]
nope not getting that smart bomb
you can't fool me with that smart bomb
talk I'll say the lasers that you can
just avoid them in the beginning they're
probably they're pretty fine
hate the ring thing that's what she said
about this game and the ring things in
the game ah when they die the ring is
the worst
I just don't register the ring as like a
thing that can kill me and it's the
thing that kills me most that guy this
guy sucks I don't care what you say
come on man enough with the thousands of
ball things alright it's all it's just
an old bit I think you know what do we
think the next boss's name is gonna be
cuz they're definitely coming up soon
ultra death sir kill a lot maybe just
kill bot could just be killed on cool
dead sir kill a lot is what I am I'm
this weapon spreads great don't care
what anybody says the ring man the ring
thing gets me every time
we gotta be yeah we're over a hundred
deaths right where are we with the thing
oh it's 12:01 alright do we think we can
reach the next bad guy what do we think
to ring things double rings all right
I'm gonna give it to one more board
after this and if we don't get the boss
then we're quitting through today
because I just can't
[Music]
saved as many humans as I could what do
you want for me
I feel like the bad guys gotta be right
[Music]
this is I like how it changes
perspective here that's fun oh here it
comes
I think this is the bad guy I think the
music just changed I think shits about
to get real oh Sh it's definitely
getting real regardless
[Music]
dude this is awesome music
[Music]
I love this me here we go in for
surprise ah damn it this music is
awesome Jesus Christ you know it's not
awesome all the pink things this guy's
shooting at me and I died I'm [ __ ]
stupid Oh
thankthank
they think everybody in the church is
yellow pink thing when they you see a
pink thing coming that way I'll know
there's a thing thing pink thing Jesus
he's trying to slide the little he's
trying to slide these little circles in
man and I don't appreciate it I'm
missing him with my rocket oh god what
is this gonna be oh jesus what is
happening this is like a music video
from hell or the 90s whatever you prefer
oh my god now he's shooting pork with
chips and be cool man this guy is like a
he loves gambling and he loves throwing
stars what's happening here he's back
pink ding
[Music]
I don't need it I don't need any of this
no don't make me start over don't we
start over all right if I can't beat him
by the next continue or quitting uh
which is gonna be not I'm just died
three times oh this game is so addictive
Jesus h-he roost too much going on
[Music]
cool perfect I can't even make it to the
bad guy
[Music]
go I just want one where it's 12:05
alright one more shot and of course your
prime okay a mouse and that's it
they got the laser baby
[Music]
all right and of course our prime there
we go I love Oh God
hit him with a full-on laser attack
[Music]
Jesus
[Music]
you can just get kind of inside his
bullets I think is the key here
Oh Mikey I mean I died
[Music]
[Music]
alright [ __ ] nailed his ass here we go
[Music]
poker chips
[Music]
poker chips
[Music]
poker chips
[Music]
it comes
railed it right there sorry chat I can't
look at you right now I love you all
shit's too intense oh don't make me
start over
Jesus
yes
man the controllers so sweaty right now
you guys
it's crazy sweaty [ __ ] is that eight
nope
coming coming in hot dude oh no that was
it that was it everybody that's gonna do
it for next machina today's screw cocoa
I gotta go upstairs and and work on the
next coolest camera um thank you so much
for joining us peer absolution Gingras
served double zero Marcus 92 dizzy death
schleppy Pete bird mug Moshe shish a lot
of great names today in the chat thank
y'all for joining us we will see you
next week Tuesday Tuesday extreme cocoa
and pay attention to twitch.tv slash
Aaron Blair if you want to see more dumb
games I'll see you guys next week on
Tuesday see you and make sure to watch
the show tonight with Chris Hardwick
Parcells another person I can't remember
bye
you